the Joe Rogan experience that's one of
the more interesting things about the
sport there's all these trade offs it's
like you want to have that super
one-shot knockout power well then you're
not gonna be able to do it very often
you know you blow your gas out it's like
having a big v8 engine you stomp on the
gas it drains that tank it's true yeah
like you see it though with with uh like
explosive guys right like Connor sure
does it seems like in the five round
fights he struggles a little bit like in
that fourth and fifth round it's not the
same pace he had him once too and
sometimes in two three in the third
round he comes out hot yeah I mean maybe
that'll all go away if he stays at 170
yeah and you're fighting guys that are
205 you're fighting guys like yeah I
mean like he hates extremely taxed
really good but I mean like and I've
I've kind of on the on the Brendan way
like today I'm a car or not rider man I
think I like what he's done in the sport
um I just I don't see him beating khabib
and I've had this conversation with
Brent a lot as like ever I don't see him
being him ever like ever and I'm not
Brendan think well here's the baby
Brandon used to give me this whole spiel
cuz I was on I was on his show below the
belt as well and we had this
conversation right before the fight
happened and he goes on he's like oh if
he fights the way he fought against Alec
quinta and this and I'm like it's
completely different if you're trying to
shoot for could be to shoot on eloquent
to who's like five seven you know it's a
different game than chin up somebody
who's really glad wrestler yeah and a
good wrestler yeah he's got some pop in
his hands yeah you know and he knows and
he knew what the fight that he knew that
could be was gonna try to take him down
Kabir's me and people gotta remember
during that week Kabhi went through five
or six opponents remember which would be
Pettis supposed to be somebody else was
like it went through all these people
max Holloway my family they pulled them
off the wake up that's right yeah I mean
it was literally last minute and so when
all of that happens you're up the same
fighter you were when you showed up in
Vegas or wherever the fight was supposed
to be thinking you're gonna fight this
person and so I get I cut him a little
slack in that fight and then fighting
someone like Alec wit - who's a [ __ ]
Savage that guy like he's so good people
and never never never gets the credit he
deserved absolutely Savage
and um and just a gamer and so when you
have to shoot on someone I don't know
how tall he is at five seven five eight
you know but it's a lot harder to get
low on someone like that and get the
takedown on him so when I was telling
Bren I'm like he's a if he stands with
him he's gonna get knocked out well who
did the drop in in that fight you know
it was kabhi Eve did the drop in because
when you make someone fear your takedown
that much
your natural reaction is to drop your
hands real quick to try to get the under
hooks and he threw that right hand like
a fastball - yeah a whip and so what he
and that's in all the years I've trained
with him he's just learned like what he
does he drops and dips his head and
comes back over with the overhand left
to the overhand right and it finds its
mark he sees it before he throws it and
he most guys will just throw blindly he
dips his head comes back up and he sees
his shot and then he throws it it's
different and majority of the time it
lands and I've been on the other end of
that shit'll quite a bit I can't [ __ ]
stand it
[Applause]